le danemark a adopté une loi il ya
quelques jours qu'ils organisent une
sous traitance de la prise en charge des
demandeurs d'asile il s'agit ni plus ni
moins que d'envoyer des demandeurs
d'asile dans des pays de transit par
exemple rwanda où leur demande serait
étudiée
outre que cette politique pourrait être
coûteuse et contraire à plusieurs
obligations internationales du danemark
par exemple le principe selon lequel on
ne refoule pas un demandeur d'asile de
son territoire ou encore la règle qui
interdit toute expulsion collective d'un
état en référence évidente ici aux
déportations des juifs pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale et la question
que pose cette loi danoise un état
membre de l'union européenne
et bien c'est de savoir si la france
pourrait faire de même et n'en déplaise
à ceux qui sur l'échiquier politique
site laden marque en exemple il ya une
différence de taille entre nos deux pays
lors de l'adoption du traité de
maastricht en 1992
le danemark a négocié de ne pas être lié
par les règles européennes sur l'asile
la france ne bénéficie pas de cette
opt-out et doit donc appliquer les
directives européennes qui imposent
d'accueillir les réfugiés
quoi de plus cohérent la france a elle
même votées en faveur de ces directives
on pourrait donc dire dans l'union
européenne 1 2 et à deux ambiances mais
enfin pas tout à fait car le rwanda a
publié un communiqué cette semaine pour
dire notamment son opposition à ce
système qu'il n'appliquera pas et de
toute façon à ce jour aucun pays
notamment en afrique n'a accepté la
proposition du danemark d'accueillir ces
demandeurs d'asile alors la loi danoise
expression de sa souveraineté sur ses
frontières ou gesticulation politique